okay great i have a terminal velocity
now what do we ask
next if the object reaches 80
of its terminal velocity before striking
the ground
sure that the point from which it would
drop was about 511 meters
above the ground okay so how do i
evaluate that
have to think about this right um if we
were to jump from some infinite height
okay you're gonna have um immediately
this force is acting on you
this force begins acting on you two but
at the start it's zero
right because you're falling from rest
so there's no resistive force
on something that isn't moving to begin
with but this starts to increase and
eventually it's going to increase an
increasing increase
until it you know gets arbitrary close
to this weight force that's going
downwards
but this question is telling us that we
don't get there right
the point or rather the object is going
to strike the ground
before it hits its terminal velocity
it's only going to get to 80 percent
of its terminal velocity so i'm going to
be solving
for when that's going to be equal to
zero
okay so being this is going to be a
displacement question and i have this
answer up here for what i should get
at the end i'm going to need to take
this force equation
and i'm going to have to get it in terms
of displacement instead of in terms of
velocity which is what i
produced up here because you're never
going to solve this equation and get
x equals 511 because there are no x's
here to begin with
so therefore let's write this part b
instead of writing force f for force i'm
going to say force is mass times
acceleration so i'll write that as
m times x double dot will do i've been
using that
because i'm going to solve for x
eventually and that's equal to
what did we say it was going to be 980
take away v squared on
10. okay now at this point here i can
say
hold up a minute i'm trying to solve for
x eventually so i really just want this
x double dot on its own i'm going to do
some form
integration so i don't know why i wrote
that m there because i already have
the value for m it's a hundred so i'm
going to try and isolate that
acceleration part of the equation on its
own i'm going to divide through
by that mass so that gives me
9.8 of course it does because that's
mass times or rather
this is mass times gravity here so
dividing through by mass sends us back
to gravity
and then you've got minus v squared on a
thousand
okay now remember like i said my
destination here is to get something
with regard to displacement so
i need to introduce x's into this
somehow and i've already got these
so the question as we've posed many
times before is what form should
i put acceleration in to make it easiest
for me to get to the destination i'm
after
is it the time destination is a
displacement destination
being that it's displacement this time
the most suitable form to write
acceleration
i'm guessing is going to be v dv on dx
and you can see why that's useful
because i have an expression
um i have a function here in terms of v
so therefore having this v
dv here means um the left and right hand
sides can play ball with each other
so i've still got that 9.8 minus v
squared on a thousand
on the right hand side okay i can tidy
up a little bit further i'm going to try
and get towards this
separation of variables idea by dividing
through both sides by v
so that'll give me uh let's put this as
9.8
on v minus v on a thousand
uh and then what i want to do is i sort
of want to get this right hand side
together into a single
fraction you've seen this before because
it will make integration
easier so when i put this together it
looks to me like i'm going to get
a denominator of a thousand v so
multiply this fraction
by a thousand and multiply this fraction
by v so that will make my denominator
a thousand v there's dv
on dx and now i'm ready to get all my
v's on one side and all my x's
on the other so if i divide through
let's see here by i might do one more
thing to make this a bit easier for me
to see i'm going to put a minus sign
there
and that flips around the order of the
difference on my numerator
i want that because having a positive
value for v in my what's going to become
my denominator will just make
integration
easier less minus signs flying around
that's dv on dx
there okay now i'm ready to go i'm going
to divide through by everything you can
see
here without the minus sign i'll leave
that minus sign over there on the right
hand side
so that will give me 1000 v
all over v squared minus 9800
i will leave the dv where it is and i'll
multiply through
by dx on the right hand side
and this is more or less ready to go
right i can integrate both sides one
with respect to v and one with respect
to x but don't forget you know when you
have a look at this
integral that you're going to get on the
left hand side the integrand is almost
in the form
f dash on f the only difference is that
if this is f
then the f dash i'm looking for is 2v so
in order to
achieve that if i think of this as 2v
that means there's going to be a 500
on the outside multiplying together to
give me the 1000 v that i
actually have okay so from there
what i'm going to do is get a 500 i'll
do the integration now
log of v squared minus nine thousand
eight hundred that's on the left-hand
side and then on the right-hand side i
just get this nice linear function
plus the constant that comes from both
of the indefinite
integrals okay now at this point here
i've got this constant integration to
evaluate how am i going to do that
well i think back to what i know from
the question it says
we've got this object and it falls from
rest where does it fall from and the
answer is
it falls from somewhere and we want to
show that that's 511 meters above the
ground
but we can just define that place to be
wherever we want and being that i'm you
know considering this whole downward
journey as the
entire thing i'm not worrying about how
it got up there you know maybe it was a
parachutist
you know skydive or something like that
or a bomb or anything else that you
might drop
i don't care where it came from its
particular destination i'm just going to
call that
the origin so i'm going to say for
convenience
initially
i've got a velocity of zero because
falling from rest
and x equals zero if the drop point
is the origin and i can just define it
as that and everything else will kind of
fall into line so if i've got a
v and i've got an x of 0 how convenient
that will let me evaluate the constant
fairly straightforwardly so i'm going to
get 500
log of when you put in the v
equals zero you get negative nine
thousand eight hundred
over there on the right uh left rather
and you get zero
plus c over there on the right so i've
got my value for c
that's going to be equal to just that uh
left hand side there
so i'm going to substitute that back
into the line i had
above so therefore 500 in fact i can be
even lazier than that
this is the line up above so i'll just
grab that there that's going to be equal
or added to 500 log of
my negative there we go 9
800 all right and now what i want to do
here is i just want to rearrange this a
tiny bit right
if i add x to both sides that will make
x positive and now it's the subject
and then i'm going to subtract this term
from both sides so
this term is going to stay put on the
left
and then what i'm going to do is
subtract this term that i got over here
on the left hand side so let's duplicate
that over here
you can see i can do some factorization
and even combination of these logs
so once you have 500 out the front and
then you've got these two log terms
when you subtract a log we know that's
the quotient
of the terms on the inside so therefore
let's draw some nice big fat brackets
there i'll get negative 9800 on the
numerator
and i'm going to get v squared minus
9800 on the
denominator that's what's equal to x
okay now uh what was i trying to solve
right i was trying to solve
for uh where the object was dropped from
which i've defined
as the origin and the way i can know
where it was dropped from is because
when you impact the ground
you're going to reach a velocity of 80
of the terminal
velocity right and i already worked that
out in part a
so i can say the object will reach
80 percent of
the terminal velocity which was i just i
think i denoted that as v
with a t subscript for terminal uh v
t when v equals well it's just
uh 0.8 there's my 80 times
the 99 meters per second that i worked
out earlier which is
79.2 if you go and check that on your
calculator
so all i'm going to do is take that
value of v and substitute it into
my displacement equation because here is
displacement in terms of any given
velocity
so i should be able to find the place
where the velocity hits this just by
substituting it in so i'm going to get x
equals 500 times log of
that negative 9800 is up the top
and then i'm going to get 79.2
squared minus 9800
on the bottom and if you go ahead and
you evaluate that what you're going to
find is
it's 510.916
some other stuff if i'm remembering
correctly um
which of course rounds to 511. but think
about what this means right
i'm defining the drop point up above
wherever i
fell from as x equals zero and then i
drop
in the positive direction right i've
defined downward as positive
so therefore um my displacement is 511
meters
below wherever i came from and that's
when i hit this
eighty percent of terminal velocity so
therefore i can conclude
if if i stop from zero and 511 meters
downward is how far i traveled
then where did i drop from answer 511
meters
above the ground because that is the
difference between them so i can
conclude that
if i use a pen instead of the laser
pointer
therefore object drops
511 meters above the ground
and that's my conclusion so what things
do we need to keep in mind here number
one
read the question really carefully to
determine what kind of force or
acceleration equation you're going to
write
you can see if for example i had an m in
here
and had you know this was multiplied by
a hundred you would not get this
terminal velocity of 99 because
the model that we had created in an
equation wouldn't match this information
that was provided in the question that's
the first thing
the second thing is terminal velocity
even though it doesn't tell you it
doesn't spell this out if you think
about what terminal velocity means which
is when
force the net force approaches zero
because you're not getting faster and
you're not slowing down
really then you can use that to you know
evaluate the terminal velocity just by
solving for when that force is equal to
zero
and then lastly when you think about
this question of uh
find the point from which it was drop
and show that it's particular it's equal
to a particular value you might not get
told that value
here at least we knew where we were
headed so that's why when i got this
number i was like
check i am headed in the right direction
quite literally think carefully
about what you're defining uh like say
for example here i've defined the
the drop point as the origin and then
i've sort of gone from there
think carefully about what you're
defining as where and then uh
interpret your results like 511 that's
actually how far i've dropped
in the downward direction and then use
that to actually answer the question